Stannis Baratheon: My brother, Robert Baratheon,
had raised the banners of Storm's End, our
ancestral castle, against the Mad King Aerys.
Jon Arryn of the Vale and Eddard Stark of
the North stood with him, and Hoster Tully
of the Riverlands would join.
But their lands were far from ours and separated
by the combined strength of the West, the
Reach, and King's Landing itself.
Even Robert's own lords were against him.
It was the hardest choice I've ever made:
my brother or my king, blood or honor.
Aerys ruled by right of all the laws in Westeros.
Everyone knew the price of defiance.
But there are deeper, older laws: the younger
brother bows before the elder.
I followed Robert.
Early in the war, Mace Tyrell's indecisive
victory at Ashford cut Robert off from Storm's
End.
Instead of pursuing Robert, and risking his
record, Mace Tyrell turned east and laid siege
to our home.
His vast army and navy encircled us and preventing
any resupply by land or sea.
If a wagon tried to reach us, it was burned.
If a ship tried to land, it was sunk.
We were locked inside Storm's End to starve.
But Robert had commanded me to hold the castle
no matter the cost.
He could ill afford to lose his ancient seat,
which had never fallen.
While Robert smashed Rhaegar on the Trident,
my men ate the dogs because the horses had
already been devoured.
While the Lannisters sacked King's Landing,
we ate the rats.
If the smuggler Davos had not slipped through
the Tyrell blockade with his onions, we'd
have eaten our own dead.
But I held the castle until Lord Eddard remembered
us, and marched to lift the siege.
The Tyrells didn't even put up a fight, and
Robert threw a feast to celebrate Lord Eddard's
"victory."
I was sent to the royal island stronghold
of Dragonstone to deal with Viserys and Daenerys,
the last surviving Targaryen children.
Before I arrived, however, they had escaped
across the Narrow Sea.
Robert was furious.
He stripped me of Storm's End and gave it
to that prancing fool Renly, my younger brother.
Davos Seaworth: Wars are not as good for smugglers
as you'd think.
Every harbor fills with guards and inspectors,
and the seas fill with blockades and pirates
paid by each side to prey on the other.
Though I had no love for the Mad King, I'd
grown up around the power of King's Landing.
I figured this Robert Baratheon would end
as the other rebel lords: burned to ash.
But he didn't.
The North, the Riverlands, and the Vale joined
him.
And in the taverns, people drank to Robert's
health openly.
"Brave fools," I thought.
But I had a family who'd be left in the cold
if I lost my head.
When Mace Tyrell marched on Robert's home
at Storm's End, I spied the end of the rebellion.
The castle was garrisoned by Robert's younger
brother Stannis and a small guard, and would
not hold out for long.
When it fell, Robert would be homeless, and
his support would bleed away.
This, I knew from experience.
Months later, Stannis was still holding the
castle.
Nobody cared.
But on voyages, I had seen what famine does;
and I thought of all those men in Storm's
End, who would die unmourned and forgotten.
No better than Flea Bottom orphans.
I told his wife, and myself, that I'd get
a high price for the onions and salt beef.
In truth, I knew I'd be captured by the Tyrell
galleys or drowned.
But I was too stubborn.
Later that night, in the dark, in a tiny boat
with a black sail, I cursed myself and the
moonlight as I waited for the tide to turn.
When it did, the wind beat the sail so hard
I ripped it down, fearing the Tyrell ships
would hear.
Luckily, they had grown lax.
With muffled oars, alone, I steered my cargo
through the treacherous currents and snarls
of rock that gave Shipbreaker Bay its name.
The waves finally carried me, soaked and near-blind
from seawater, through the mouth of the cavern
beneath the castle.
Then Stannis Baratheon arrived.
The siege had left him gaunt, but not weak,
never weak.
He greeted me and accepted my onions with
cool courtesy, betraying no emotion even as
all wept.
He doled out the food to his wife and each
of his men before he ate himself, a portion
no larger than any other.
When he finally thanked me, I could see his
mind had already returned to the castle's
defense.
His duty.
After Aerys fell and Lord Stark lifted the
siege, Stannis summoned me.
For my salvation of Storm's End, I was to
be granted a knighthood, a keep of my own,
and my son taken into Stannis's personal service.
"Davos of Flea Bottom" had become "Ser Davos
of House Seaworth," and my son would serve
the king's own brother.
But for my previous crimes as a smuggler,
I was to have the fingertips of one hand taken
off above the highest joint.
Stannis held that I had flouted the laws of
the land for years, and a good act does not
wash out the bad.
In one fell swoop, or five, Stannis gave my
son a future and my family a name that I could've
never imagined, nor earned, on my own.
I still keep the finger bones in a bag around
my neck to remind me of what I was, and what
I owe to Stannis.
For during my many years as a smuggler, I
visited many ports, taverns, and back alleys,
and saw many things in this world, but never
justice.
Until Stannis.
Robert Baratheon: Rebellion!
The crimes of House Targaryen were too heinous
to go unanswered.
The noble Houses of Baratheon, Stark, and
Arryn, united to oppose and overthrow the
line of the cursed dragon kings.
While Ned Stark and Arryn secured an alliance
with the Tullys of Riverrun, I called the
banners of Storm's End and rode out in force
against the Mad King and his minions.
Gods, those were some battles!
Our first victory occurred at Summerhall where
I faced off against an army of dragon loyalists
and won three battles in a single day, three
in one day!
Seven hells, that was a glorious day!
We tried to take Ashford Castle in the Reach,
but the Tyrells beat us back.
We had to regroup.
My army was pursued north by Aerys's army
and took refuge in the Stoney Sept in the
Riverlands.
When the Targaryen army entered the town,
the sept bells tolled, a signal to the townspeople
of the battle that was to come.
As the Targaryens searched from house to house
for me, the combined forces of Ned Stark and
the Tullys swept into the city.
Gods, what a day that was!
It's now known as the Battle of the Bells.
We overwhelmed the Mad King's forces and sent
them scampering back to King's Landing.
Aerys's son, Rhaegar, who started the whole
damn thing, finally emerged from hiding in
the South and assembled his own army to face
us.
As for the Mad King, he must have been pissing
himself.
The battle that would decide the fate of the
Seven Kingdoms occurred at the crossing of
the Green Fork of the Trident river.
Rhaegar commanded the royal host, which was
some forty thousand strong.
My forces were outnumbered by nearly five
thousand men, but that didn't matter.
They were fresh, but we were battle-hardened
and had justice on our side.
As the battle raged around us, I faced off
with Rhaegar.
The stag and the dragon right there in the
ford of the river.
I fought with the fury of ten men, raining
blow after blow upon that vile prince before
burying my war hammer in his chest.
I hit him so hard, the rubies on his armor
broke free, flinging them into the stream.
They call it the Ruby Ford now.
With that scum Rhaegar dead and the royal
army shattered, our next move was to make
for King's Landing.
But I'd sustained a few wounds in the battle
and was unable to ride.
I sent Ned Stark to the capital to face the
Mad King and make him pay for his crimes.
Viserys Targaryen: The Targaryens, blood of
the dragon and the last of Old Valyria, were
loved by their subjects and admired far and
wide as the greatest dynasty in the history
of the western world.
But the peace and prosperity of nearly three
centuries of Targaryen rule were shattered
by the Usurper, Robert Baratheon, and his
band of traitors.
House Baratheon owed its very existence to
the Targaryens.
Was it not Aegon the Dragon, himself, who
elevated the bastard Orys Baratheon in the
War of Conquest?
And what of the Starks?
The Lannisters?
The Arryns of the Vale?
All had been spared and allowed to keep their
lands when Aegon could easily have wiped them
out.
Centuries later, the Usurper and his lackeys
repaid Aegon's benevolence with treachery.
There are some who dare to claim Robert and
his allies had reason to rebel.
They say the crown prince stole the Usurper's
lady love.
They say my father, King Aerys, murdered Rickard
Stark and his son without just cause.
Whether these charges are true or not, it
doesn't matter!
The dragon answers to no one.
Aerys's good name has been besmirched in the
years since the rebellion.
He has been called a dangerous madman, a monster,
a tyrant that brought his tragic end upon
himself.
Lies!
My father was a victim of weaklings in his
council!
Lackwits who failed him in his hour of need,
and let the rebellion spin out of control!
But it was not enough.
The royal army was crushed at the Battle of
the Trident.
It was there the valiant Rhaegar met Robert
in single combat, but the gods betrayed him,
and he perished by the Usurper's hand.
As the Field of Fire had marked the end of
the Andals centuries before, the Battle of
the Trident seemed to herald the end of the
dragon kings.
When word reached the capital of my brother
Rhaegar's death, my father Aerys moved to
protect me, as I was the surviving heir to
the throne.
He sent me to the island fortress of Dragonstone,
along with my mother, Queen Rhaella, who was
great with child.
But as my father, my king, Aerys Targaryen,
prepared to defend his throne to the bitter
end, little did he know of the horrors and
betrayals that awaited him and our family.